so i decided to give my opponent a  40-point lead and try to come back  i start out on defense so i'm sending  that pressure early  he tries to go for a fake field goal and  it doesn't work  i get the ball back and score my first  touchdown  then i couldn't catch this pick  i still score next drive  he thinks he's able to run on me  he finally passes and throws a pick  scoring my third touchdown  he finally breaks a good run on me but i  make a clutch tackle  all good though koozai  lurking [ __ ]  i'm already up to 30 points and it's not  even half time yet  he then goes for a fake pun which i  wasn't expecting at  all but it doesn't matter i still stop  him  only down 10 points to start the third  i scored on the first play of the third  quarter  i score again taking the lead  i'm in full control at this point not  giving him a chance  he's had enough  gg  [Music]